with ornate patterns and islamic
references the current exhibit at new
york's asia society clearly shows its
persian roots why zikami and his
interest in alchemy but the exquisite
craftsmanship isn't all that curator
fereshta devtari wants her american
audience to see
when you look at the works theory will
realize that they're not just mere
decorative works they have very profound
messages to convey even if at times
the messages are concealed
rebel jester mystic poet contemporary
persians features 20-plus living artists
from iran and its diaspora
about a third of the artists on display
still reside there in a country long
seen as an american adversary
the work on display conveys many aspects
of persian identity to a western
audience more accustomed to seeing
modern iran through a political lens
at times the work plays with stereotypes
to present a more nuanced view this
image of an open wound or even a bullet
hole from war and peace she's connecting
this idea of war with the pursuit of oil
to gender identity it's sort of uh in a
way a rebellion against what is expected
of of iranians of iranian women the art
reveals the people behind the politics
would they be able to
show these works in iran
most of them have been shown in iran yes
most have been shown but of course you
have to be also sensitive about certain
rules sometimes using humor to quietly
subvert authority the biggest
misconception is that all women are
depressed
and they're only they are under the veil
and they're repressed
or beauty to convey something dark the
idea of mirrors reflecting truth
these contemporary persians like all
great artists compelled the viewer to
look again for a completely different
perspective
kristen salumi al jazeera new york